7 26 Tuesday morning I'm Heather Mills a  midterm election day is here let's go  ahead and take a live look now at one of  the nearly 130 polling locations across  Clark County this is in Centennial hills  and you can see voters are already in  line those doors opened about 25 minutes  ago and it's quite a long line already  polls closed tonight at 7. if you're  already in line though at that time you  can remain in line until you've cast  your ballot if you do choose to mail in  your ballot it must be postmarked today  it must reach the election Department no  later than 5 p.m Saturday of course you  can also drop off your ballot at any  voting location everything is posted and  listed at 8newsnow.com